herd immunity seemed to be the holy
grail to ending this pandemic for a long
time
the hope was that if enough people
develop immunity to saleskov 2 through
vaccines and infection the spread of the
virus would slow down
and once the herd immunity threshold is
reached kovid19 would gradually
disappear from the population
humans managed to get there at least
once in the case of smallpox
which were eradicated with the help of
vaccines
but two years into this pandemic we have
to admit
this will not happen with saskov2 herd
immunity now seems like a naive dream
from the early pandemic days
because we've seen all these mutations
and we're still understanding like how
well this immunity that we may have
works it's it's really hard to think
about getting to a point of hurt
immunity now
if eradication through herd immunity is
off the table the more likely option is
that covert 19 becomes endemic at some
point it means that still the virus
spreads in society can spread in society
and
but not not wildly not everybody so you
would only see
more or less outbreaks
in special populations or in certain
circumstances
but therefore the effect on society is
less and that's what we call an endemic
state
endemic means the overall number of
cases remains stable and therefore
predictable
because vaccines and previous infections
have created enough immunity to stop
uncontrolled spread
we are actually living with many endemic
diseases the flu is one of them all
malaria and measles
so what would living with endemic covert
19 look like
scenario 1 covet 19 turns into a
seasonal risk that comes and goes in
waves just like the flu
scenario 2 covet 19 is permanently
present in certain communities around
the world but case numbers are stable
scenario 3 covert 19 becomes a
children's disease with the first
infection being the worst
older people have less severe symptoms
due to immunity they acquired through
vaccines or previous infections
some of my colleagues would think that
um it will become just a very normal
disease and we
it will be more one of many which is the
most likely likely scenario and
therefore we we will deal with it like
we're dealing with with flu for example
so are we on the brink of this pandemic
becoming endemic
i think with what we've seen with covet
19 thus far it makes it really clear
that we're not at the endemic stage yet
i wish by the end of 2020
two we will come to us we will come to
the um endemic stage of this
in infectious period
but it depends on various other factors
as well on the side of the pathogen and
side of society so
and if a new pathogen or if the pathogen
evolves or if we don't manage to
vaccinate as many people as necessary if
we change our behavior
things can go differently we can't be
sure
and endemic doesn't mean that a disease
is not dangerous anymore it can still be
deadly for some and it wouldn't
necessarily mean the end of all
protective measures either
take the case of malaria
sleeping under mosquito nets or taking
anti-malarials are part of the routine
when dealing with this disease
i hope we will learn from this pandemic
and we will keep some of the good things
which we have learned for example every
year thousands of people died of flu
and now we saw that with uh high g
measures distance and
wearing of mask in in populated places
uh flu almost disappeared so we could
certainly in the future maybe think
about that some of these measures might
be sensible
[Music]
so masks could still be a part of
seasonal covert 19 prevention
even in the endemic stage
but for now we still need to focus all
our efforts on actually getting there
through vaccines and infection control
you